ihr seht es ist ein wunderbares
endergebnis meine sehr geehrten damen
und herren das ist jetzt 21 37 am 25
oktober 2008 sind und ich saß gerade
eben da haben überlegt was könnte ich
heute für ein video machen und dann kann
man kleine rohde es hier nicht darum
videos machen sondern ich meine du musst
es dir anschauen ist vielleicht ganz
verbot hat ja zwei rap tracks hoping bzw
1 auf seinen von hand ein bei jam fm
woher diese no sense wird machen wir
durch sind was hier mal zeigen wer
kannte das noch nicht und ja jetzt sind
wir hier
ich habe generell gar nicht so viel von
tanz fotos gesehen bisher also ich weiß
dass es ganz gut gibt und ich weiß was
er macht und ich schaue dann aber selbst
nicht aktiv deswegen habe ich aber nie
was von seiner musik gehört aber auf
jeden fall sagt mir gerade eben da und
max hat wird diese raps von taxol
gezeichnet ich dachte mir
demnach sei und zwar wenn ich mich heute
zum ersten mal in meinem leben mit tanz
oder bisschen näher beschäftigen und max
wird mit hans roth und seine musik
zeigen und ich würde sagen film ok
kläger die von mir also als allererstes
könnte krasser sprache auf dich zukommen
einige worte könnten wenn du das nicht
machst du solltest du jetzt besser
umschalten
eine verwechslung getroffen sondern ich
sagen ist nicht welche sprache aber das
ist echt krass zu sagen also ich habe
sich ein stück weit selbst nicht rappen
aber der floh klingt echt krass also
fürchtet sie dass fließt die sprache ist
ja normal
das hat jetzt verstanden und der
kindheit ein gestandener danach wie
kommt man darauf auch schon probiert
muss ich ganz ehrlich sein dann
irgendwie die worte kommen so klar
erreicht wenn ich das probiere so länger
irgendwie sowas sohn aus wenn es mäßig
jetzt sofort mit dem dann verschwimmt
ist so war bei ihnen kommt dass er so
klar ist wer seine sprache an
die kaum wieder reflektieren was diese
passiert erklärt tanzte wurde paul hat t
shirt mal geht heute der band lässt sich
november wieder gespielt und lag
irgendwann also entfernt so ein bisschen
wie südkorea
ich muss sagen wenn das das ist das
tanzverbot songs macht kann ich
verstehen warum leute das feiern weil
ich glaube kein anderer mensch auf der
erde würde auf die idee kommt mit einem
ford t shirt in rapture zu gehen und
dann halt das dazu machen lasst mal ganz
kurz die kommentare das ist übrigens der
linken
die börse muss mal gucken sondern auch
mit die kommende wahl also die die lücke
die person die das der vorgeschrieben
wird dann gehen wir tauchen bei der
suche ein tanzverbot
[Musik]
ich erkenne so leiser so musste das ist
auch wieder ohne irgendwas dazu gesagt
einfach so rettig ansteht sind selber
einfach zu boxen sagte aber auch ich
muss meine ist tanzverbot was du
brauchst kommt man mal sowas passiert
geschaut habe
wenn er davon redet dass mit diesen
geschmack wiljo leute damit passiert wie
der tanzverbot was ich hier vor meinem
gesicht befindet ist womöglich der beste
bestell bürger den ich jemals gegessen
habe beziehungsweise denen es überhaupt
gibt und der test jetzt einfach die
bürger ja er viele videos von so was
discovered knackt fertig sein ja das ist
ja wie früchte er sei natürlich waren
wir ganz kurz hatte er tränen in den
augen
wie kann etwas so geil schmecken hört
ihr natürlich korrektur wie die augen
glänzen digger verfällt leider schafft
er das ist auf jeden fall eine wichtige
kann
eigenschaft so diese wahnsinnige
leidenschaft wir essen insbesondere
fragt muss los bruder leben das man
nicht mein leben ist sein sound gegen
herausgabe hat ja auch fortgesetzt
werden
arbeitsplatz ist organisiert guckt sich
sehr interessiert selbst
na ja wohl war da ganz kurz mal ein
bisschen wie viele flaschen stehende 123
milchflaschen dass das mädchen dann
fünfmal musste trinke meinen kaffee mit
teuren zutaten und fühle mich dann
schlecht weil meine daten cds ist auch
[Musik]
viel bestellte pizza
ich habe da so meine sache musste noch
ein genuss war so ein persönliches
highlight sind mir immer einen transport
salat im entree tutorial wiemann
es ist ja ekelhaft kurz vorher heute
sieht man das natürlich sagen ich habe
tatsächlich schon mal eine youtube kacke
vom tanzverbot gesehen da wenn wir diese
schlacht damit aber es hat sich jetzt
alle erste mal dass es mir tanzverbot
videos als solche leute dabei hilft
wieder ein tanzverbot und bekommt von
meiner allerersten ausgabe von kochen
mit tanzverbot zu gemütlichkeit habe ich
mir eine wunderschöne care zu besorgt
ein bisschen durch wir sind anders ihren
reden hört aber dass er mit dem
zeitpunkt hätten in der nacht geschehen
12.24 der salat das stromnetz
abgeschnitten langsam haben wir jetzt
echt schon annehmbare stellen wir
hinbekommen geht das ganze besteht jetzt
aus diesen teilnehmen also ich find's
lustig wer ist für salate gekürzt wird
so erklärt es geht übrig sondern dieser
stelle an heraus die habe ich wirklich
inspiriert hat mich auch einmal etwas
gesünder zu ernähren auch wenn ich denke
dass mein einkauf kommen nicht durch
gesundes essen regiert werden soll denn
dass es nicht der lifestyle überleben
sollte
wenn ihr jetzt natürlich ein
professionelleres brett habt das brett
zwei euro kostet ein wenig natürlich ein
professionelleres brett habt dann bleibt
natürlich nicht so viel kleben die
professionelle können wir noch etwas auf
waschmittel ich selber kommt ihr seht es
ist ein wunderbares endergebnis der
familien als anfänger sehr zufrieden
damit bin was übersetzt die absolute
spitze wäre wenn er so ein thema wir
eine gute gekocht es ist heute leidet
das war mein erstes mal tanzverbot
schauen und tanz und musik das ist
einfach ein video was mir ganz spontan
entstanden ist
wir uns einfach gerade hingesetzt und
baten idee damit sofort gemacht habe ich
lange darüber nachgedacht die ganzen
leute da habe ich einfach mal vergessen
die abmoderation zu machen ich wollte
schnell noch mal sagen ich habe
tatsächlich vor diesem video also bevor
wir dieses video aufgenommen haben nie
tanzverbot geschaut und ich könnte
forschern das annehmen dass ich glauben
werden weil der halt schon in größerer
youtuber ist und so auch viel im
gespräch ist aber ich weiß nicht bisher
habe ich immer wenn ich diese video
vorschläge gesehen hab ich mir dazu dass
wir ein bisschen zu gut und ich muss
sagen soll es zusammenfassungen auch
wenn ich ihnen im heutigen video glaube
ich kein einziges mal habe lachen sehen
aber seine eigenen witze
ich glaube der typ hat einen recht guten
sinn für humor das war so was von diesem
video leute hier darüber die bücherei
kriegt ja noch eine für euch
vorgeschlagene folge von einem kanal
taktiker abschaut weiter und bis zum
nächsten mal macht's gut